مرحبا بكم من جديد في اسبوع هذا العاشر لا
تزالوا الاحتجاجات وتعم مختلف المدن
الايرانيه باختلاف الجغرافيتها لكن الهدف
واحد رفعوا ظلم وقمع النظام ففي العاصمه
طهران انضمت احياء جديده لساحه الاحتجاج
لاول مره كما انضم المزيد من الايرانيين
للشوارع تمديدا بالقمع الذي يتعرض له
المحتاجين في المدن الكرديه فيما اشعل
المتظاهرون في مدينه
برزجه جنوبي ايران النار في مكتب النائب
في البرلمان الايراني ردا على انضمامه الى
الدعوه لاعدام المتظاهرين الذين تم
اعتقالهم مؤخرا وتصاعد الاحتجاجات في
ايران واستمرار قمع النظام رافقه انذار
امامير ان وصف مفوض الامم المتحده السامي
لحقوق الانسان
في ايران بالحرج بدورها كشفت منظمه حقوق
الانسان الايرانيه عن ارتفاع حصيله قتل
التظاهرات في ايران الى 416 قتيلا حتى
الان على الاقل بينهم واحد وخمسون
[موسيقى]
ومنذ لحظه انطلاق الاحتجاجات في ايران
تعددت وسائل النظام الايراني لاخفاء اصوات
اولائك المطالبين بالحريه لكن تقريبا
لشبكه سي ان ان الامريكيه كشف وجها اخر
للنظام طهران متهما قوات الامن بالعنف
والتحرش بالمتظاهرين بمراكز الاحتجاج
وتؤكد التقارير معلومات لروايات حقيقيه
على لسان ضحايا عمليات اغتصاب كان اخرها
انتهاكات جسديه ونفسيه بحق صبي مراهق
تقرير المحطه الامريكيه نقل عن مصادر مطلع
قولها ان قوه الامن صورت مشاهد العنف
الجسديه وحولها الى اداه الابتزاز
المتظاهرين واسكاتهم وفقا لتقرير فقد
تتضمن مركز احتجاز اورميه في مقاطعه
الاسلام اباد الايرانيه اكثر من 40 امراه
معتقله وفيان دون السادسه عشر من العمر
كانوا قد تعرضوا لضرب المبرح والتحرش
[موسيقى]
في محاوله اللي صار في انظار العالم عما
يدور في الداخل اخرجت ايران ورقه الملف
النووي فدعوه الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه ايران لاظهار المزيد من التعاون
قابله تصعيد ايراني بتخصيب اليورانيوم اذا
كشفت وسائل الاعلام ايرانيه عن بدء طهران
في تخصيب اليورانيوم الى درجه في نقاء 60
في المئه في موقع فورد النووي باستخدام
اجهزه طرد المركزي اي ار سته وهو ما اكلته
ايضا وكاله الطاقه الذريه
هذه التي تقوم بها ايران في مواقع اخرى
ايضا تقل عن 90% اللازمه لصنع الاسلحه
النوويه لكنها اعلى بكثير من نسبه 20%
التي كانت قد وصلت اليها طهران قبل
اتفاقيه 2015 مع القوى الكبرى التي نصت
على عدم التجاوز نسبه التخصيب
3.67% ايران سرعت بالرد على ما وصفته
باتهامها بعدم التعاون مع الوكاله الدوليه
لطاقه الذريه اللي اتهم وزير الخارجيه
الايراني حسين امير عبد الله كان الوكاله
بالتدخل في شؤون بلاده محذرا من ان طهران
ستردوا باجراءات مماثله على اي قرار يصدر
من الوكاله ضدها فيما اكد المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه الايرانيه ناصر كنعاني ان
الاجراءات التي اتخذتها منظمه الطاقه
الايرانيه جاءت ردا على تبني قرار من ثلاث
دول اوروبيه والولايات المتحده بفرض
عقوبات ضد طائره
في المقابل اعرب البيت الابيض عن القلق
واشنطن العميق بشان التقدم الذي تحرجه
ايران في برنامجها النووي والتطوير قدرته
الصاروخيه الباكستيه المتحدث باسم مجلس
الامن القومي للبيت الابيض جون كيربي قال
في اجازه صحفيه اكد ان الاداره الامريكيه
لن تسمح لايران بامتلاك القدره الحيازه
السلاح النوويه كما ادانت كل من فرنسا
وبريطانيا والمانيا قصيد ايراني
معنى من بروكسيل منى السيلاوي الباحثه في
الشان الايرانيه ابدا معك من هذا التصعيد
النووي اعلان ايران بانها
ستبدا التخصيب بنسبه 60% في منشات فوردو
هل لهذا علاقه بالاحتجاجات المستمره
يعني جمهوريه الاسلاميه تنظر ل- اا السلاح
النووي يعني ايضا روسيا ارسلت هذه الرساله
الواضحه لدول الغربيه لانها تمتلك السلاح
النووي لا تسترجع اوروبا وامريكا مع كل
جيش ضد نظام السوري النظام الروسي يتخذ
قرار قرارات جديه همم على رقم كل هذا لم
يستطيع ان يتخلف مواجهه مباشره مع بروتين
ايران اذن ترى في صلاح انه هو رادعه ممكن
ان همم تحافظ على النظام وتمنعها من
انهيار فبالاساس كانوا يعملون على الحصول
على السلاح النووي كانوا يتمادون مع
المجتمع الدولي لا يصل الى هذه المرحله
الان الاحتجاجات مستمره لذلك تخوف
الايراني اكبر
فيحاولون ان يسرعون للحصول على القنبله
النوويه في حال قررت الدول همم اتخاذ
قرارات او ارسال ملف ايران الى مجلس الامن
سيكون لديهم قوه رادعه للمجتمع الدوليه
نعم طيب هنا بالعوده الى موضوع الاحتجاجات
وزياده حمله القمع مع التقارير التي تتحدث
عن التعذيب في السجون كذلك وارتفاع عدد
القتلى حتى من بينهم همم اطفال برايك هل
يستعد النظام كذلك
لربما قمع اوسع لسحق هذه الاحتجاجات
مع الاسد اغتصاب حتى الرجال في سجون ليست
اول مره يعني في حركه الخضراء اول مره
يعني تحدثوا بانها بكثافه كثير من الضحايا
خرجوا همم طالب همم يعني حاولوا ان همم
يذهبون الى المحاكم ولكن دون ان ي جدوى
النظام لم يجرد على همم الابداعات اللي
قدمت من قبل الضحايا كم ما قضيه الاغتصاب
حتى السقف بدايه الثوره همم الخمينيه كانت
كثير من البنات غير متزوجات كانوا يعني
كانوا ضمن المعتقلات وصدر بحكم الاعدام
بحقهم بودينيا وشرعيا لكن ما كان يجوز
اعدام الفتاه البكر فحتى منتظري احتاج على
خميني الرد كان من حرس الثوري كان انه نحن
قمنا بتزويج تلك الفتيات قبل العيد اعمل
اللي كانت هي اغتصاب لكن الفتيات يعني
قضيه الاغتصاب والتعامل السيئه غير انساني
وغير اسلامي غير ديني همم بدات مع بدايه
الثوره فليست حدث جديده ولكن الان اعلام
يتحدث عنها في حرب في بدايه الثوره يعني
كانت همم كلام تصلي لها المعلومات ايضا
الشعب لم ليست لم يكن لديه كل هذه
الامكانيه حتى يتواصل مع الاعلام بحركه
الخضراء العالم حاول يعني ممكن نقول سكتت
عما يحصل في في ايران ولكن هذه المره في
يعني انذار متوجهه لايران لذلك اخبار تصل
ولكن ليست اول مره مع الاسد
الايراني مباشره من بروكسيل شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
غداتها سلسله من الغارات الجويه
والعراق باتت لهجه ورئيس التركيه رجب طيب
اردوغان تتصاعد يوما تلو الاخر تحدث عن
احتمال اطلاقي عمليه بريه الواسعه في
سوريا قريبا متواعدا بمهاجمه المسلحين
بالدبابات والجنود اردوغان اكد ان بلاده
عبر غراسها الاخيره ردت على التفجير
الاخير في اسطنبول بتدمير اهداف لمسلحين
اكراد في شمال العراق وسوريا
منذ قليل
اعلموا امام جميعا في اسرع وقت ممكن
باستخدام دباباتنا وجنودنا
في اطار هذه العمليه العسكريه التركيه
افاده مراسل العربيه بان اثنين من القوات
مكافحه الارهاب التابعه لقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه قتل واصيب ثلاثه في استهداف
مراكز لهم تقع قاعده كبيره للتحالف الدولي
شمال غرب مدينه الحسكه واوضح مراسل
العربيه
الكبيره لوجود القوات الامريكيه واخرى
دوليه الى جانب مقار لقيادات الصف الاول
في قصر
قوته سوريا الديمقراطيه تسعى الى وقف
التصعيد التركيه ضدها عبر التواصل مع
واشنطن وماوسكا والكريم لان قال انه يتعين
على جميع الاطراف تجنب الخطوات التي قد
تؤدي الى تدهور الوضع محذرا تركيا ايضا من
زعزعه الاستقرار شمالي سوريا المانيا
بدورها دعت الى رد متناسب يتوافق مع
القانون الدولي بعد ما نفذت تركيا ضربات
جويه شمال سوريا والعراق
معنا من عمان استاذ العلاقات الدوليه
وافضل النزاعات الدكتور حسن المومني دكتور
حسن اهلا بكم معنا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه
لوقف التصعيد وضبط النفس هل برايك همم
ستتوقف تركيا عند الغارات الجويه
بالمسيرات فقط ام بالفعل ستشن عمليه بريه
كما توعد اردوغان
مساء الخير لك والمشاهدين الكرام من مالها
شك في الموضوع التركي الموضوع مزمن ومساله
التصعيد التركي ومساله التهديد بعمليه
عسكريه الاولى سابقا كنا نتحدث وتحدث
الرئيس التركي عن مساله ضروره ان يكون
هنالك حتى منطقه عازله او منطقه امنيه في
الشمال السوري بهذا الجانب طبيعي والمحرك
الرئيسي هي المساله الكرديه القدير
الكرديه بالنسبه لتركيا حقيقه القضيه
الكرديه هي قضيه لها جوانبها الاقليميه
والدوليه لها جوانبها تتعلق بالموضوع
الكردي التركي وايضا لها بتقدير الخاص
بظروفها الداخليه المتعلقه في تركيا
والمتعلقه ايضا في اردوغان بنهايه المطاف
واعتقد نهايه المطاف انه الرئيس التركي
اردوغان يمكن قد يعتقد بان الظروف
الاقليميه والدوليه
مواته
اجراءات باتجاه الاكراد خاصه عند ديت عن
ان البي كي عند ال- ال- ال- وايضا عند
الحديث عن مساله قصد او الفراغ اللي الان
في فراغ سلطه في شمال سوريا بالتالي وشمال
الشرقي وبالتالي تعتقد تركيا ان هذا
الفراغ يؤدي الى حاله جذب او حاله جاذبه
للمسلحين الاكراد ايضا اضيف الى ذلك مساله
الانتخابات الداخليه التركيه المساله
الكرديه بالنسبه لتركيا مساله همم
وجوديه تتعلق بالامن القومي فبتقدير الخاص
حتى يثبت مصداقيته قد يتخذ خطوات عسكريه
نعم طيب همم المساله ليست فقط في شمال
سوريا العراق ايضا هناك تركيا وايرانيه
كذلك تستهدف الاكراد في شمال العراق هل هو
اتفاق همم تركي ايراني ترى على همم القضاء
على الاكراه
يعني هو عمليا في توافق اقليمي بغض النظر
على اختلافات عدم السماح بان يكون هنالك
كيانات همم كرديه او تصل الحاله الى ان
يكون هنالك دوله كرديه او قيادات يعني
سواء كانت ايران سواء كانت سوريا سواء
كانت تركيا طبيعه تركيه هي الدوله الاكثر
بمعنى انه الموجودين فيها اتراك فبتقدير
الشخصي هنا تلتقي المصلحه على مساله ضروره
كبح جماح تطلعات الكرديه القوميه التي قد
تلقى اما الى تاسيس عن نوع من الاحكام
الذاتيه والحكم ذاتي في هذه المناطق او ان
تسعى الى الاستقلال بهذا الجانب فلذلك في
التقاء مصلحه بهذا الاجانب ولا ننسى ان كل
الدولتين يعني ايران عندها مشكله داخليه
لا شكل الموضوع الكردي الموضوع يعني
تاريخي لهذا الامر لكن ايضا باستحداث ان
هنالك تهديد يواجه ايران تهديد ق وكل هذا
الجوانب همم بتقدير الشخصي هو نوع من
ترحيل الازمه بالنسبه لتركيا نفس الشيء لا
تنسى انه في انتخابات هنالك ايضا العناصر
القوميه التركيه اللي بالنسبه الى الموضوع
الكردي مساله وجوديه فبتقدير الشخص نعم
يعني في هنالك استغلال لظروف اقليميه
محليه في سياق همم محاوله ضبط الطموحات
القوميه الكرديه دكتور حسن المومني استاذ
العلاقه الدوليه وفضل النزاعات من عمان
شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
باتت الحرب في اوكرانيا كل يوم رحنا
مجريات جديده مع كل تقدم استراتيجيه
مختلفه طريقها في مصاري هذه الحرب واشنطن
مستمره بالدفع الى المفاوضات منها عالميه
واخرى سريه بحسب تقارير غربيه وردت في
الاونه الاخيره لكن جديده التطورات كشفته
صحيفه بوليتيكو عن مسؤولين ان الاتحاد
الاوروبي في اطار الفردي حزمه تاسعه من
العقوبات ضد روسيا الصحيفه لم تقدم اسماء
او اعداد محدده من الاشخاص الذين قد
يتاثرون بالحزمه التاليه من العقوبات الا
ان الدول الاتحاد الاوروبي بحسب الصحيفه
قدمت قوائمه طويله حيث يقوم خبراء
المفوضيه الامر حاليا بتحليلها القصه
تكمنون ان في حال اقرار عقوبه جديده فهي
كفيله بان تاخذ موسكو خطوه الى الخلف
باتجاه المفاوض
وبموازته ذلك رئاسته الروسيه تسلم الرئيس
طبلادينيو بوتين مشروع اتفاقيه السلام مع
اوكرانيا وذكرت الرئاسه الروسيه ان
التقارير التي زعلت تسلم بوت مسوده اتفاق
سلام مع اوكرانيا قبل قمه مجموعه ال 20 هي
تقارير زائفه واشار الكريم لين الى ان
روسيا منفتحه على محادثات سلام مع
اوكرانيا لكنه اتهم في الوقت نفسه كيف
بوضع عراقيل وشروط تعجيزيه
في المقابل لا تزال المساعدات الغربيه
تتدفق على اوكرانيا حيث اعلنت رئيسه
المفوضيه الاوروبيه ارسل لافندر لاين عن
تقديم مليارين ونصف المليار يورو اخرى
لاكرانيا من الدعم لها مضيفه ان اوروبا
تعتزم تقديمه 18 مليار يورو خلال عام 2020
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه المزيد عن اخبار
المونديال والمزيد كذلك عن الفوز التاريخي
السعودي في فقره الرياضه القمر
[موسيقى]
الزمن يفعل فعله العميق ويغير اقتناعات
ويغير كثير من الافكار وبالخصوص
اقتناعاتنا المتورمه وربما الكتابه هي بكل
اشكاله الابداع بكل اشكاله
الجمال
روافد الجزء الاول الجمعه السادسه والنصف
على شاشه العربيه
[موسيقى]
لا تتنازل ولا ترضى بشيء عادي لكن المراعي
اجود زبادي مع زبادي المراعي كالاكل الف
[موسيقى]
ما من جديد تحت شعار ان كنت لا تحب ماسك
معنا هكذا تعمل شركتكولوجيه امريكيه لجلب
الموظفين السابقين الذين فصلوا من شركه
تويتر للاستفاده من خبراتهم وتجاربهم رفقه
الطائر الازرق قلب شركه تويتر لقاضمه
حديثكم الى الدعوه امام شركه القانون
الامريكي لتصريحها الف الموظفين دون اخطار
لا اساس لها وتمثل الدعوه المقدمه اول رد
من تويتر على الدعوه الجمعيه المقدمه التي
رفعت في وقت سابقا هذا الشهر بموجب قانون
الاتحادي يلزم باختار الموظفين قبل 60
يوما من تصريحهم بشكل جماعي
من سامسونج ومن امام المقر الرئيسي لشركه
ووتر معانا مراسل العربيه حسين طود حسين
اهلا بك معنا جديد الاقالات في تويتر وكيف
سيعوض ماسك الكفاءات التي غادرت الشركه
تحيه لك صهيب اخر موجه من الانقالات كانت
البارحه عندما عقد ايلين ماسك اجتماعه هنا
في مقر الرئيس لتويتر في سان فرانسيسكو
كانت الموجه طبعا طالت همم
مبيعات في الشركه ولكن همم الجدير بالذكر
ان وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه نقلت عن
موظفين كانوا في الاجتماع قولهم بان ماسك
اكد لهم ان مرحله ال- الاقالات قد انتهت
الان سيكون هناك مرحله جديده هي مرحله
التوظيف قالوا ماسك يسعى للتوظيف في قسمين
همم الهندسه والمبيعات همم من جديد طبعا
هو لم يحدد نوعيه المهندسين والرجال
المبيعات او رجال المبيعات الذين سيظفهم
ولكن هو همم لم يستبعد مثلا على ان يوظف
مهندسين في مناطق مختلف مختلفه من العالم
في الهند في اندونيسيا في البرازيل وهنا
في الولايات المتحده
طيب كل هذه الاعداد من الموظفين ان كان
الذين اقيل او ان استقاله اا هل تم رصد اي
اعطال فنيه او اي توقف في الخدمه خدمه
تويتر
بالفعل صهيب خلال نهايه الاسبوع تحدث عدد
من مستخدمين تويتر على ان نظام حمايه همم
النظام الحمايه
الملكيه الفكريه التلقائي قد توقف وما سمح
لعدد من المستخدمين بدفع افلام باكملها
مثلا فيلم افاتار هذا امر ممنوع في
الولايات المتحده نظرا للملكيه الفكريه
هذا بحسب خبراء يشير الى ضعف وهشاشه نظام
التويتر الان بسبب النقص في العاملين
والتقنيين الذين كانوا يشرفون على مراقبه
جوده النظام وعلى ما يتم بثته على امور
كثيره تتعلق كيفيه عمل هذا النظام في ال
ال السحابه الالكترونيه وهمم ايضا بسبب
عدم وجود تقنيين يقومون بالسيانته البنيه
التحتيه لنظام تويتر حسام يطرد مباشره من
امام المقر الرئيسي لشركه تويوتا
فرانسيسكو شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
الله وصلنا الى ختام هذه الساعه تفكيرا
فرحه سعوديه
تاريخي للاخضر في كاس العالم امام
الارجنتين اول منتخب اسيوي يهز شباك راقص
التانجو
[موسيقى]
مع ارتفاع قتلى الاحتجاجات في ايران تحذير
اممي من خطوره الوضع والنظام يصرف الانظار
بورقه التصعيد النووي
[موسيقى]
بالدبابات والجنود تركيا تهدد بشن عمليه
بريه واسعه شمالا سوريا والغرب يحذر من
تدهور الوطن
اوروبا تنفذ رائحه طويله من العقوبات على
روسيا وتمدد فرصه المفاوضات
تتهموا كيف بعرقله السلف
شكرا لكم على كرم المتابعه المزيد دائما
يبقى على العربيه على صفحتنا على مواقع
التواصل الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]